well my great inspiration in my life are
sort of two forces I think one was
religion which is very very important
particularly for my mother and father
but also for the members of our family
and has been incredibly important in
terms of my life particularly facing
some of the real challenging times that
I've had to face members of my family
that have been lost other kinds of
tragedies and also the role of family we
were large less being a larger family I
was the youngest of nine the last to
come along sat at the little table on
the side of the the room always had the
battle to get my views across or to be
able to express it but I had
extraordinary role models my father who
was very ambitious for his children and
was a great disappointment devoted to
her faith and also the love of history
and her children my older brothers who
were great heroes of mine and we're
inspiring figures all the way through my
life also demonstrated to me that the
political process could work and could
be responsive to people's needs and
challenges my sisters who in their own
way were not elected to any office but
also we're very important in terms of
their own commitment in expanding
opportunity for people my sister Eunice
Shriver the founder Special Olympics now
in a 144 countries and going to be world
focus in China in just a few weeks from
now my sister Jean who worked for very
special arts programs which has been so
important in helping people with the
disabilities and also who are artists to
work and collaborate together and my
other sisters
and I was also inspired by a an older
sister rosemary who was mentally
retarded as she was a very important
figure in our family and she was very
included and I think from the earliest
days I recognized the that she was a
rather special individual and I could
see how my mother and father and how my
brothers and sisters reacted to her and
I think it was probably an extraordinary
force in my life about recognizing the
value and the special grace that
individuals have that have physical or
challenges in this instant
mental retardation and the importance of
their value and what they could give to
the family and also the recognition that
people out there in our society have
special needs and they as a as a family
and as a as a country in a society we
ought to be able to try and reach out to
our fellow citizens and respond to those
kinds of human beings